is about 40 minutes good evening and
thank you very much for for joining me
this evening to to talk about my newly
released book in bed with Wall Street
before we get into that first off I want
to thank my great good friend John kunio
and his partners here at Kimio Gilbert
and lo Duca
for graciously hosting us this evening
so thank you very much for that I
wouldn't be here if I didn't have some
really great woman behind me I first off
I want to thank my editor at Palgrave
Macmillan
Emily Carlton and her team so thanks to
them I want to thank my agent Cynthia
zigmund at second city publishing who
fondly
in early 2012 I wasn't even thinking of
writing a book until Cynthia asked how
come you haven't written a book I want
to thank my publicists at Merrill Media
Merrill mass media and Merrill Moss and
Sarah housement as they say behind every
good man there they're a bit there's a
better woman or better woman and I've
got a great team most of all I really
want to I want to thank my wife honestly
without my wife I wouldn't have had a
blog she's been amazing I mean teaching
herself how to write code and to grow
the yeah the blog again without the blog
there's no book
so most of you know me as having a
background in finance I've been working
on the south side of Wall Street for not
quite 25 years have been in and around
Wall Street the last 30 years and the
one thing that I was I heard on when I
was trading on Wall Street was the
management would come over and say Larry
what's your position it asked me that at
7:30 in the morning at 8:15 at noontime
6 7 8 9 times a day what's your position
the position could fluctuate depending
on what was going on in the market I'm
sure there are many people around this
town as well around Washington
constantly being asked what's your
position oftentimes it's best to find
out what the other person's position is
perhaps before stating your own
but just for a frame of to kind of frame
the context of what my position is in
writing this book before I get into some
of the topics on the book I think it
would be helpful
perhaps if I just kind of frame the
context of my background just a little
bit so that people can really have a
sense for who I am and what courses
through the pages in this book I'm one
of one of eight kids I grew up in a
neighborhood section of Boston seven
boys and in that sort of environment
there was one thing you had to do you
had to compete if you weren't competing
you were falling behind your you weren't
even involved in the game to begin with
so I was the six out of eight kids again
seven boys if you aren't competing you
were going to get beaten up or left
behind so you had to compete we look
down or all kind of frowned upon people
in the neighborhood and again within a
250 square yard there were about 25 or
25 other kids would look down on maybe
the kids who weren't competing but worse
than not competing and this this plays
out in this book where the kids who
cheated the kids who cheated honestly
I'll leave it to your mental imagination
it wasn't a pretty sight so that day
that was a core part of my character you
know that this competing growing up in a
city neighborhood riding the orange line
into the Boston Public Latin school
going in there as an early teen and
sitting in the this auditorium and
looking up in the Hall of this hallway
and seeing names like Hancock Adams both
Finch both Finch patella who actually
was the architect for the US Capitol and
to sit there as an early teen the weight
of this intellectual curiosity in this
intellectual capital that had a that had
a formative impact on me this
intellectual curiosity and having
teachers challenging me at a very early
time what's your case support your case
again that plays out in this book in
short order I made my way to the College
of the Holy Cross which we would
consider the the finest Jesuit Institute
in the country said with all due respect
to those in this in this neighborhood
who go to also a great Jesuit school
here in Washington over at Georgetown so
but at Holy Cross we were competing to
win on and off the field so again is
this whole sense of competition but
again what was it that the Jesuits
taught us pursue the truth pursue the
truth make your premise support your
case and and do it unceasingly that also
had a formative impact on me as I was
developing say we have it I did have the
benefit of an older brother who made his
way to Wall Street I went down and
visited him during my my senior at Holy
Cross and I knew in right away this is
this is the place for me these are my
kind of people
the pace the competition the markets are
figuring things out the intellectual
curiosity all this sort of stuff and I
oh it did a debt of gratitude to Larry
Fink whom I would define currently as
the king of Wall Street for giving me
the opportunity at a very early age to
come on to the mortgage desk at First
Boston truth be told I probably did not
appreciate just how great an opportunity
that was at that point in time but they
weren't going too far out on a limb they
offered me a two-year commitment like
most young guys out of college it was
two years then go back and get your MBA
I told Larry in very short order the job
that I wanted was right there on the
trading desk he responded and said well
you're not going to know anything for a
year so go get me a cup of coffee and
you know keep your nose clean
perhaps I got a little bit lucky I
always try to make as many friends as
possible and be as value-added I did get
my opportunity on the trading desk I
never did get that MBA but but so be it
stay for seven years at first Boston on
Wall Street to announce it in these
certain sectors of the market it gets
very small very quickly reputation is
everything because everybody knows each
other
who
the good guys who was maybe not quite so
good thought
to me there was no premium high enough
on reputation reputation was everything
and God forbid that I have across to
anybody and he started to perhaps speak
speak ill of me I never could could
allow that to happen
I just wanted to constantly be
collecting friends in relationships but
I could have an opportunity opportunity
to do business I ended up moving to Bear
Stearns in 1990 that was a unique
experience
I mean bear was a dramatically different
firm than first Boston from a cultural
standpoint the way that the businesses
were run I became a better businessman
going to Bear Stearns ended up working
for an individual whom honestly I think
was the single best guy worked for on
Wall Street I'm happy to mention his
name Kevin Finnerty meant the world to
me from both a professional and a
personal standpoint and why was that
Kevin and I shared a value system in the
sense of ethics and which permeated the
business without giving anything from a
competitive standpoint and so that a run
at Bear Stearns was a great run I stayed
there for seven years
Kevin ended up moving to UBS and I
followed him to UBS and then ultimately
did JPMorgan Chase but I also wanted to
constantly be expanding my skill set I
was a trader for 15 years I didn't want
to just be a round peg in a round hole
so how do I continue this intellectual
curiosity that you know from my
formative years understanding risk of
different products different sectors of
the market to me that was a way of
growing my career and so if I needed to
take a step back in order to take
multiple steps forward that to me was a
prudent prudent approach the world that
very interesting in 2004 2005 2006 and
beyond
I left JPMorgan and early oh-6 whether
that was divine intervention or not who
knows I at that at that point in time
honestly there were definitely signs of
cracks in the system could I have
projected what would have played
out to two and a half years later no I
couldn't but there were definitely some
signs of stress and so I as as a result
of that I was in no rush to go take a
job at another large bank you can
oftentimes get into these large banks
but it's very difficult to actually get
back out of them because they put these
golden handcuffs on you so I was I was
afforded the opportunity to leave
JPMorgan which which I took to start
pursuing entrepreneurial activities both
from a business and not-for-profit and
then the world melted down and a friend
of a friend here in NBC asked me to
explain to his audience at his blog what
just happened with Lehman Brothers and
so I wrote a commentary 50 people
responded to that commentary and that to
me was indicative of the the appetite in
the demand for explain to us what's
going on on Wall Street so I wrote some
more commentaries and got an equal
number of responses when I realized that
if I really want credibility as a writer
I need to put my name out there I can't
just be LD or some other sort of
pseudonym if I really want the readers
to say you know what I believe in this
this individual I have to put my name
out there and so I did so I introduced
myself to the to the blogosphere said
this is who I am this is my background
and really what motivated me at that
point was this whole idea of that I
could be of service this idea that I've
got a body of knowledge about the the
shadow banking system the technicals in
the market the fact that this
securitized markets that I was in
represented between 40 and 45 percent of
the credit that flowed into the economy
that that's meaningful in the fact that
those markets to a very large extent
shut down in 2008 and I knew what the
ripple effect that that would have on
the economy as a whole so they said this
is what initially motivated me
start writing writing the blog this blog
cents on cents and then as things really
started getting interesting I knew what
happened on Wall Street I knew why it
happened but really what intrigued me
was how did this happen meaning where
were the regulator's how did the banks
you know get around the the regulatory
oversight that was what really intrigued
me I set aside in my afternoon in
mid-january 2009 to watch the
confirmation hearing for Mary Schapiro
figuring this is going to be great
political theater and hopefully we will
learn something and honestly after 90
minutes I realized they didn't lay a
glove on her and I turned off my TV and
I said I'm going to go start to learn
some stuff and I did I started looking
into this organization called FINRA
because when I worked on Wall Street the
the cops that you needed to keep your
nose clean was the NASD the National
Association of Securities Dealers I was
not aware that the NASD had merged with
the regulatory arm of the New York Stock
Exchange to form FINRA so I'm thinking
who is this FINRA within about an hour
I learned exactly who FINRA was I said
okay this is the NASD and when I read
through their 2007 annual report and I
just said wow talk about conflicts of
interest and then I started to look at
their finances and saw they've got an
internal investment portfolio
so we're saying here's a self regulatory
agency entity effectively walking the
floor overseeing the tables but they've
got their own money in the game I write
further and said ok they've got an
ombudsman and they've got boards to
minimize or make sure that there's no
conflicts of interest but as my trading
instincts kicked in and I was like you
know what I'm gonna challenge that at
this point in time my blog is in test
mode I had about 12 people reading the
blog six of them are my brothers
and I'm firing awfully you know these
questions in there you know nobody's
reading this stuff but
we went live in early February and I'm
the initial intersection that I had were
with some investors who had been
defrauded in the auction rate securities
market and I started questioning like
how was it that FINRA had an investment
in auction rate securities and
intuitively I was thinking they must
have liquidated these bonds so I started
going down that path I continued down
that path and in summer of 2009 my blog
really started to take off after I saw a
case that was filed I read this article
in Bloomberg America's securities and I
called the law firm that was bringing
that case and that phone call came to
these offices and I initially spoke to
Bill Anderson and and then I spoke to
John don't forget John saying you're the
fellow that writes that blog I said
indeed I am
and John said you're looking at the same
stuff we're looking at I said how about
that and continue to track that case had
the good fortune of meeting John and
Bill and the colleague Richard
Greenfield down at the courthouse in
Foley Square that fall of oh nine blew
me away was the fact that aside from
myself and one reporter from Bloomberg
but the cases weren't being more fully
covered I was like wait a second this is
literally I mean the the vortex of where
Wall Street and Washington and the
regulator's all come together a riveting
case asking incredible questions that to
me would go back towards explaining a
lot of how bad practices actually played
out on Wall Street I mean my adrenaline
was flowing like never before and I had
a voice and although my wife would
caution me like you better be careful
before you hit that send button on the
blog I was but again kind of going back
to the principles that had developed
with a Boston Latin or at Holy Cross
know your stuff
you've got to know your stuff document
it connect the dots from the America
case then John said well what do you
know about this other case that being
the one for standard investment
chartered I said oh honey thing about
that case so well we've got some other
stuff to talk about and I started
concurrently run down the auction rate
securities path
the American path the standard
investment chartered path whistleblower
actions in learning about whistleblowers
where who had been ignored intimidated
or fired and thinking you know what this
is wrong on so many levels and I've got
a voice you know what I'm going to
embrace these people allow them to
utilize my blog so that they can not
only speak their own voice but find
kindred spirits who are going through
the same travails and so you know thanks
you know I was very very happy to have
launched the blog if there wasn't a blog
there wouldn't be a book continued down
all these paths because when I think of
it I think okay 2008 there was only one
year that that could be compared to and
that was 1929 and so although there are
many agencies and entities whether it's
in this town or New York or elsewhere
around the country that we're trying to
you know we're trying to get the economy
going and that's important because the
economy obviously impacts all of us but
what's the basis of the economy the
basis of the economy is trusting
confidence and where do we get trusting
confidence we get it from the truth
that's it this isn't a Republican issue
or democratic issue or an independent
issue we need the truth and again you
know so I just continue to deep dive
into the legal briefs or these investor
actions you just said you know what's
you know what's the deal and the deeper
I dove the more intriguing it was but I
had a blog and it was great but then it
it all kind of changed in late 11:00 in
early 2012 I exchanged notes with Bill
Cohen the bill has written some
duis books on Lazard frères Oldman Sachs
Bear Stearns built to me kind of had a
unique space in the literary world
because there have been some great books
written on Finance but bill was really
to me the only one from the sell-side
who wrote in kind of an aggressive
fashion so it was not an overpopulated
space we had coffee on the upper west
side compared some notes we ended the
coffee whether he said you should really
think about writing a book and I was
like I've got a lot of archives material
you know what do I even start
I don't know the last thing that I
thought I would share was one of these
auction rate securities investors again
I got a call from them just yesterday
again just you know down and out I can't
access my cache my kit my daughter's
sick said I need to put you in touch
with Al Lewis who the Dow Jones reporter
al spoke with them about twenty minutes
into the conversation because do you
mind if I hit the tape tape button right
now said let's roll and 36 hours later
my story about you know my background
and my blog hits the other news wire and
all of a sudden the traffic on the
blog's spiked so that was a good thing
and I got a call from Cynthia zigmund
heissen and Larry I'm Cynthia with
second city publishing how come you
haven't written a book I said Wow and I
said okay what's entailed in writing a
book and she said this is what you got
to do the proposal the outline the
chapters the marketing I said I think
I've got a great story and I really
believe that but what she impressed upon
me was she said this book probably would
never happen if it weren't for the
platform of that blog and just the the
connections through the blogosphere that
have brought me to many of you today
and in the past I mean I look around and
I'm going to meet Danielle Brian here
from the the project of government
oversight and her colleague Michael
small verbal I think is out there I mean
I initially got engaged
the folks at Pogo I think it was early
20:10 because I started to read some of
the materials that they had worked on in
terms of whistleblower protection and I
said these are good people doing the
right thing and I engaged them and we
had some fabulous dialogue standing up
for for whistleblowers and the fact that
people out there because a lot of people
said well how come nobody on Wall Street
has ever spoken up and I would respond
there have been people who have spoken
up but they've been ignored intimidated
or fired that's wrong that's scandalous
but it's happened and it's happened not
only a junior level it's also happened
at very senior levels and these are
stories that I want to bring to bear in
my book these are details that the
American public in my opinion needs to
know it's not only that but you know
John's cases the work that John and his
colleagues did on these cases these are
these are historic type cases that gets
right to the core of the whole Wall
Street Washington dynamic and the fact
that you know this self regulatory
system is not in the best interests of
our economy so again I don't want to go
on I could I could talk for hours so I
will spare you failure that that's my
story I've been thrilled would be the
the reception that the book has received
to date but again you know I'm just the
mouthpiece this is really the story of
individuals who I wanted to give a voice
to and explain in layman's terms in a
narrative this isn't work this is an
easy read it's a couple hundred pages
but for serious serious students there's
about a hundred fifty reference
documents totaling almost 20,000 pages
there's a historical perspective I went
back to the late 1800s went through the
depression into the 1930s so it gives
both a historical perspective but I also
lay out some pointed reforms some
challenging reforms that in my opinion
people in this town should be challenged
what do you think of this because these
are serious issues we're living through
very serious times and ultimately you
know this is for you know I'm writing
for my kids and I'm writing for you know
all our kids our kids deserve better
they really do so this is a serious book
there there will be some people that
won't appreciate my my having written
this but you know what too bad so on
that note I thank you again for for
coming here this evening thank you for
your interesting support and I would
certainly like to open it up for you
know any sort of Q&A that the book has a
cover that equal to its content and so I
would suggest that you show the cover
because it's down right witty well I
appreciate that and I got to give credit
to the design people at at Palgrave
Macmillan for designing that I we went
through actually a fair number of titles
for this book I but ultimately when I
when I thought of in bed with Wall
Street I said that nails it and and
actually looking back the first person
to use that phrase the February at least
for purposes of this book was on
February 4th 2009 followed by the name
of Harry Markopolos
gave testimony right up there on the
hill and when he graded the SEC is
worthy of an A+ and incompetence the
follow-up was well Harry did you buy I
didn't you bring the information to
FINRA in his response was well I believe
that FINRA is in bed with with the
industry and deserving of an A+ in
corruption that's a strong statement
that is a strong statement and I I don't
put it out there lightly I mean all too
often nowadays people can throw out
hyperbole and there's a lot of noise
that gets created on the airway
absorb eight and it's the same you know
almost every night if there's a lot of
the same stuff that goes on to me the
question isn't really about more
regulation versus less regulation it's
about the appropriate regulation with
real regulators that is the key issue we
need people who are not captured by the
industry and consider across the table
from whether it's Jamie Dimon or Lloyd
Blankfein and say these are the rules
and this is how we're going to operate
those are difficult conversations but
you know what that's what our country
needs to me I mean this is why there's
this massive disconnect between Wall
Street and Main Street I told somebody
today I said you know the thoroughfare
that joins Wall Street and Main Street
it's called the Federal Reserve but
unfortunately right now
that's a one-way street and that's
unfortunate but when you look at the
statistics the numbers don't lie so
there's criticism my former partner Jed
Rakoff
now a judge that the SEC allows people
to in a sense plead guilty but not admit
that they're guilty and he said they
shouldn't do that but the person I think
who was allowing to do that was Mary
Schapiro who had been with FINRA and now
Mary Jo white the new chairman says
she's going to change that do you think
it was Mary Schapiro who was responsible
for that policy of letting them not
plead guilty well I think Mary was the
the face I think Mary was the face of
the policy could Mary unilaterally
mandate well she was in a strong
position as the chair of the SEC I in my
humble opinion I think Mary Schapiro was
appointed by Wall Street to be the the
SEC that this and so that she she was as
much a representative of Wall Street as
she was the the investing public and
when you look at the track record
between the actions
I think married to a large extent was
was hamstrung by the people at Treasury
and by the people at the Federal Reserve
the idea of first do no harm
well the fact is there was a lot of harm
done in not properly adjudicating cases
and that just has this long-standing
impact in terms of eroding trust and
confidence in the fact that I think
large parts of our country right now
would say certainly looks and feels like
a double standard to me and if justice
is misdirected then justice is
ultimately denied so with all due
respect to mr. pero you know what I
think she would get a feeling great yes
Danielle in person and as you know one
of the one of the issues that we're also
very concerned about is the inadequate
congressional oversight of this world do
you think that with Wyden going over to
Baucus of seat do you think anything is
going to change well there's always hope
right there's always hope I can he rally
you know rally some support it takes
more than one I also think that the
change where wood will really come from
is getting these issues into the public
arena so that creates public pressure
not only on Wyden but on others that you
know what they are actually starting to
get it out there and that's one of the
motivations for me to write this book is
if we can mean why did they end up with
the the stock act the stock act only
that that sat in committee for six years
it was only after 60 minutes did this
embarrassing expose that they said you
know what they actually starting to get
it out there regrettably they ended up
kind of dying the stock act back a
little bit
they certainly did they certainly did
and that's unfortunate but I
transparency is the great disinfectant
right so these issues need to get into
the public arena if and as they do and
I'm motivated honestly I am motivated to
to bring these into the public arena at
the highest level I really and put a lot
of reason then you know there is
probably a small percentage of people in
the country who I would think would not
appreciate these issues getting aired I
think about 310 million people would
have a real appreciation for this now
perhaps there are some disinterested
observers so whatever that percentage is
so let's say 280 million people you know
what we get 280 million people
interested I think we can create some
real change Larry based on your
expertise and knowledge of the past your
your engagement here in the present what
would you say your top two reforms may
be looking towards future okay great
question there are 14 reforms laid out
in Chapter 12
I can't bring people down and say oh my
god what's going on and not allow them
you know an opportunity like okay we've
got a chance for something better I of
those 14 what would I say are the top
two well certainly I would love to end
the too-big-to-fail model all right
that's going to take a while but in
terms of specific reforms I personally
think that we need a separate office of
whistleblower protection and I would
like to see that implemented for the
financial services industry and have
that served as a model for other parts
of the government so that perhaps
perhaps thought mr. Snowden wouldn't
have to feel like I need to go public
you know because if I go to the office
of whistleblower protection we're going
to perhaps get some some meaningful some
I can think of these other individuals
whose story stories I highlight who
really were abused they were intimidated
or fired I mean with some very very
significant cases that would have had a
material impact on the markets when this
fella by the name of Gary of Gary Gary
Gary having a phenomenal story I mean
this fella is an American Hero
and if he had been allowed to make his
insider trading case back in 2005 I
think that would have had a significant
impact on Wall Street so I would like to
see an office of whistleblower
protection because I my opinion that
would bring out information and allow
for the processing of information
instead of this what unfortunately right
now is this bottling up with the Justice
Department the FCC brings the
information back to the firms and
believe me if you're I mean there's a
case in here by the name of Peter severa
Peter severa worked in the compliance
department at JP Morgan and he was
blowing the whistle on an after-hours
trading case his identity was violated
by an SEC attorneys it was like wait a
second how does that work that SEC
attorney was clearly trying to curry
favor with the general counsel's office
at JPMorgan I mean that that's wrong so
that's one thing the second thing that I
would propose we've got an SEC that five
years ago was deemed an a-plus in
incompetence FINRA reports to the SEC
FINRA was graded by again by Harry
Markopolos an a-plus in corruption I
personally think that a self regulatory
model honestly doesn't work the idea
that Goldman Sachs or JP Morgan or
others can pay a regulator so that the
regulator is going to really
aggressively regulate them that to me
just on its face I mean come on and when
you actually look at the statistics I
mean I call the meter maids for a reason
but the percent for the revenue that's
generated in the industry for the finds
that FINRA imposes
it's maybe 1/10 of 1% of their top-line
revenue
I mean if you're the industry there's a
reason why you want to be self regulated
but that doesn't that doesn't help
generate trusting confidence in the
system so that I personally think a self
regulatory model doesn't work in what we
should have and this is pretty radical
stuff I personally would like to see a
financial a federal financial regulatory
review board you know I think of cities
around the country where you have police
abuse I mean there it happens and so
what happens in a lot of these cities
they come in with a police review board
they get private citizens who are
concerned for the public interest and
they form a committee to oversee the
police department to make sure that it's
run in an ethical fashion and it doesn't
allow for scandalous sort of behaviors
to go on honestly given the track record
given the track record of our financial
regulators I personally would love to
see an idea of a financial regulatory
review board implemented the powers that
be would say well we've actually just
done that we implemented this financial
stability over the Oversight Council
okay and they will oversee the
regulator's and the system problem with
that it's the same foxes guarding the
same henhouse I mean so people from the
Federal Reserve or Treasury or elsewhere
I mean again massive conflicts of
interest looks good on the surface but
how do you get that implemented
especially during challenging times so
they will revert back to their primary
interests in those entities I lay out I
think the names of about 12 individuals
who I think if solicited I mean these
are these are real statesmen you know
it's not not leaning one political party
or another I think if we went to those
12 individuals and say would you give us
three years of your time well we can
implement this financial regulatory
review board and people talking people
like Sheila Bair William Black
bill Isaac me in my opinion these are
these are real credible people there's a
fella by the name of Marvin a who's a
professor at Tufts University
who's got industry experience Gary a
Gary
loyal without pear mr. Markopolos he
certainly knows the inner workings get
these people to come in and hold people
accountable you know real accountability
and it's just this to get back towards
generating some some trusting confidence
and the fact is Wall Street the last
five years has seen volumes across so
many different sectors down over 50% I
mean the stocks are trading very well
but what is Wall Street right now Wall
Street is in oligopolies I mean that
that's to me is problematic and
oligopoly you've got just a small
handful of firms what happens in a
situation like that they hoard
information so you don't have
accessibility for information and you
end up with periodic bouts of market
manipulation and collusion I mean
whether its interest rates currencies
commodities
it just happens you know when there's
only three other guys involved in the
market you know what they're going to
talk to each other that gets into
breaking up the the too-big-to-fail
model personally think that we've got to
get back to implementing glass-steagall
the Volcker Rule to me is kind of a
distraction who who is negatively
impacted by the vocal role community
banks community banks were the only ones
I mean it seemed like good so it's a
great just to follow up on that based on
your experience and what you know can
you remain optimistic can you be
optimistic towards Wall Street now you
personally oh you know what Wall Street
is filled with overwhelmingly with good
people I mean this movie that just came
out I think you know America will look
at that and say oh you know what Wall
Street you know broad-brush that
guys that is a disservice Wall Street
overwhelmingly has good people but in my
opinion the system is broken the system
of oversight is broken people on Wall
Street are actually being negatively
impacted by the broken system but
overwhelmingly I think good people
trying to do a who do a good job if we
could just bring some some transparency
to the regulatory process and so what do
we have to do got to get the cronyism
out of it
this isn't more regulation less
regulation you know what couple folks up
on Capitol Hill
you know what the money is going to stop
flowing okay and we'll start going to
start to represent the public's
interests let's get the cronyism out of
it and you do that and you know what
you'll start to see in my opinion you'll
start to see capital
start to flow because capital will flow
when it's protected but capital has to
be protected so this does take time I
mean this is again these are kind of
aggressive measures but let's put them
out there you know I will consider this
book to be a success and then we'll wrap
it up if this if this book creates
dialogue in discussion that's all I
really want so to that end I thank you
all for being here I appreciate your
interest and support if you can spread
the word about the book so that
ultimately the public benefits thank you
very much
[Applause]
then your horse who's that books design
I've got everybody sort of home an
assigned by one right over here and one
one could sit down here on the sidewalk
Jerry
yeah